ladies and gentlemen due to all the
division and strife and intractable
hatred and violence in this country
right now I've decided to leave America
for the relative peace sanity and quiet
of the Middle East that's right ladies
and gentlemen I'm going to Israel I'm
going to take
[Applause]
that's true I'm gonna be heading to
Israel to tape another one of the travel
shows we've been to a bunch of countries
these shows are really fun going to
Israel now here's the interesting thing
this is true I may be in Israel the same
week as president Trump's son-in-law
Jared Kushner who's been sent there to
broker a Middle East solution well it
occurred to me I figure Kushner and I
have the same amount of experience with
foreign relations you know I think you
had more I might actually have more I
might actually have more so maybe I'll
get to maybe I'll you know you can make
something happen Navy anyway it's all
going to be a part of a special called
toning in Israel coming in September
[Applause]
I didn't have any more to say I just
want to see if I get him to stop right
wait you did yeah well anyway we should
hit it guys someone screwed up and I'll
find out how it sounded like a tree yeah
I think a trumpet screwed up there was
that you bender pandeiro is at you
[Applause]
you